[Musique]
nous sommes à présent dans l'atelier du
sculpteur gérard amon nos pas à maurepas
mai à paris qui nous accueille donc ici
gérard amon bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir dans votre atelier
parisien vous avez avec jacques riboud
est réalisé de nombreuses sculptures
aménagements sur cette ville de mort pas
comment vous tout simplement déjà vous
êtes arrivé sur ce projet vous étiez
alors tout jeune sculpteur sortie des
beaux-arts wii sortie des beaux-arts
tout jeune donc que j'avais j'avais déjà
travaillé connu monsieur rebbouh avant
mon départ au service militaire qui
c'est et c'était en 60 en 1960
bon ça fait un paquet d'années tout ça
hein et puis revenant de l'armée je
travaillais donc chez un architecte pour
gagner ma vie est tout en retournant à
l'école des beaux-arts
on est dans un petit champ sur un petit
chantier j'ai fait la connaissance de
monsieur rivaux jacques reboux qui était
un personnage impressionnant un peu
qu'ils sortaient de qui était un grand
industriel déjà du pétrole 1 est la
bienvenue
on a sympathisé je pourrais lire et il
était très intéressé de voir quelqu'un
juste un élève des beaux-arts et que
j'allais faire la sculpture pour lui
c'était quelque chose de d'inattendu et
c'est ce côté il attendu qui
l'intéressait jacques riboud c'est un
personnage donc un grand promoteur
puisque quand même il est l'auteur de
toutes les villes à une partie de la vie
de nouvelles aussi maurepas et
villepreux
mais c'était un homme très très curieux
et très
voulant faire des choses que les autres
n'ont jamais fait et son idée c'était de
réaliser d'aménager des sculptures en
même temps qu'il réalisait même pensé
construction tous en scène devrait très
bien comme ça c'est un petit peu dans le
vague et donc lui commençait à faire
villepreux et la lddhi m'a dit au bout
d'un moment où plusieurs rencontres
qu'il avait vu un peu ce que je faisais
et surtout il m'a dit écoutez moi
j'aimerais bien vous faire travailler et
que vous fassiez une sculpture pour
villepreux et puis donc au bout d'un
moment j'ai présenté ce projet de l'aide
de la femme maternité debout et cette
maternité debout elle c'était symbolique
quoi j'allais dire puisque nous c'était
vraiment une époque c'était le début des
trente glorieuses
ce n'est pas coulé les choses
extraordinaires se faisaient les villes
nouvelles ce comme ça et comme des
champignons dans la région parisienne
bon et est donc il m'a dit c'est alors
dont j'ai fait un beau jour j'ai été le
voir mon petit projet j'étais encore
beaux-arts voiliers et medimmune très
bien ça lui plaisait vider la maternité
la chose nouvelle l'enfant qu'on apprend
marché mais il me dit ya vraiment là il
m'a pas parlé d'argent vous m'a pas dit
comment ça va coûter
c'est après tu me mets ma demande et en
quelle matière vous allez faire ça et
bien entendu moi je j'avais pu je
m'étais posé beaucoup de problèmes et je
vais réfléchir aux questions
bien entendu quand vous êtes un grand
sculpteur vous faites en bronze et ses
terres mais ça coûte déjà très cher et l
école des beaux-arts on apprend la
sculpture écran un grand s mais on
apprend aussi appelé technique mais
enfin on est
c'est la vie qui nous fait faire des les
oeuvres après 1
et donc quand je lui ai dit écoutez j'ai
envie de la faire en cuivre martelé vous
en cuivre martelé alors il a été sidéré
et il a parlé je me souviens toujours
une chose qu'il avait complètement
séduit des vases des je suis plus
qu'elle vase qui était en cuivre qui
l'avait très intéressés et avant une
madiba écouter ok on part et c'est comme
ça que ça a été fait cette province
culture et c'est comme ça qu'est née la
première version villepreux et ensuite
vous avez continuer ce travail
alors autant jacques riboud pour
maurepas c'est là où jacques riboud m'a
proposé de m'intégrer dans l'équipe dans
son équipe
et là c'était vraiment très très nouveau
siv est exceptionnel quoique avec un
jeune sculpteur rentrer dans l'équipe
deux constructeurs où il y avait le bien
sûr te feras le le promoteur les
financiers etc
mais les architectes les constructeurs
les urbanistes les architectes et puis
même l'entreprise qui fabrique qui
construisaient les balles et les maisons
etc
ouais et moi j'étais intégré dans cette
équipe là
donc c'était absolument formidable quoi
c'était jeu très bien et j'ai travaillé
comme ça avec l'europe rue où je crois
pendant 20 ans et vous avez signé plus
d'une dizaine d'oeuvres sur cette
commune et maurepas
on n'a pas fait ou est pas noir pas
droit parce qu'à rang en comptant les
choses parce qu'on a fait aussi pas mal
de musique
vous avez vu que là par exemple à la à
l'hôtel de ville il ya les bouteilles
qui est qui il ya le cheval d'euros tel
est ce la cavalerie la grande cavalerie
ha oui hein ça ça fait quand même pas
mal d'oeuvre que j'ai fait là bas
et l'idée ce que vous me disiez un peu
avant qu'on débute l'enregistrement
c'était aussi de créer un passé dans ces
villes nouvelles en fait c'est ça le
concept et le concept de ribou
andorre son côté je dire curieux et et
il ya eu l'idée géniale c'est lui qui a
eu l'idée géniale
il y disait on construit des quartiers
neufs
il faut de leur donner une vie immédiate
il faut pas qu'il faut que les échanges
sous retrouvent sur leur passé quelque
part et il lui il avait l'habitude de
dire moi je dis je parlais des
sculptures et lui parlait des statuts et
j'ai compris pourquoi il disait statut
parce que ce statut c'était plutôt
l'esprit est justement qu'on dans les
villes il ya toujours une statue quelque
part on dans deux rendez-vous quand on
est jeune à sa petite amie où on fait du
vélo autour d'elle et la maman ahmed
saison il ya toujours la statue le
rendez-vous est lui il a l'idée dans son
idée il voulait mettre des statues et il
voulait que les gens qu'on recrée oui
qu'on crée immédiatement une vie et en
même temps un espèce de passage avec le
le passé quoi vous avez une carte
blanche sur la réalisation alors
vraiment a eu carte blanche sur les
matériaux ce qui a été fait alors
fallait bien entendu que je m'intègre là
ce problème parce que bien sûr je serais
venu afin d'apprendre à faire des
recherches esthétiques contemporaines
je ne sais pas si j'aurai plus non donc
moi je me suis j'ai réfléchi je me suis
battu je me suis j'ai fait de telle
sorte que ce soient des sujets qui soit
proche de la vie quotidienne des gens
que les gens s'y retrouvent quoi hein et
puis et jacques reboux était
certainement de mon avis puisque il a
accepté à chaque fois les choses que je
vais proposer des architectes avec qui
je travaillais aussi bien pire pour eux
que
que prédit eric rolland président qui
était quand même le grand artisan de
architecture de maurepas j'ai eu
toujours que des bons rapports quoi
extrait on en discute aide mais eux ils
étaient un peu dépassée des architectes
gt sprint statut qu'on allait mais leur
plaisait qu'à moitié
un choix en fin de compte parce que il
est séché le côté extraordinaire doré
vous c'est qu'il était vraiment en
dehors des sentiers battus il était
vraiment en dehors des sentiers battus
il a fait des choses que personne
d'autre n'a fait aujourd'hui encore vous
retournez à maurepas par exemple le voir
maintenant voir ses réalisations et voir
comment la population aussi se les
approprier 50 55 ans maintenant après
alors là je peux vous les aime j'étais
très très bon apport et ça m'a plu
beaucoup c'est pas c'est pas grâce à moi
mais par entre autres avec la société du
patrimoine la défense du patrimoine de
moore pas un avec méité qui est la
présidente
vraiment ça va créer des contacts
extraordinaire qui me qui me font
plaisir qui me l'a récemment les enfants
d'une école où je suis passé d'un après
midi avec eux oui c'est quand même pour
la sculpteure au bout de trente ou
quarante ans je sais plus c'est
impressionnant quand même que les
enfants enfin je vais pas vous montrer
ce qu'est une petite fille m'a donné
mais un coeur là et petit j'ai quand je
suis rentré le soir ça m'a fait quelque
chose quand même hein vous avez imaginé
à un moment au moment de cette
conception que un demi siècle plus tard
ses oeuvres strella auraient leur
histoire aurait vu plusieurs générations
ouais ben non justement parce que quand
on crée une oeuvre on l'imaginent
perdurer on imagine dans le temps on se
projette un petit peu pendant ce projet
ouais on en est on est dans le coup un
fou quand on est jeune moi j'étais jeune
à l'époque mais bien donc on s'imaginait
pas l'avenir c'est maintenant que je
rends compte à quel point qui a eu un
impact que les gens se sont appropriés
plusieurs fois les sculpteurs ont été
abîmés par le temps plus que par les
gens sains pour pour conclure est ce
qu'il ya eu d'autres d'autres villes par
la suite d'autres projets d'envergure
comme celui ci comme celui vous avez
mené au repas ou est-ce que ça a été
aussi difficile pour vous après deux de
passer presque à autre chose oui oui oui
oui mais j'ai jamais eu de de vrais
projets comme au repas sains dont moi
j'ai vu que j'oublie j'ai travaillé une
quinzaine d'années ont un bon bain puis
après bien entendu on avait créé une
petite société avec jacques riboud que
ça plaît à citer et on mettait à notre
savoir et notre louis notre savoir au
service d'autres communes
ouais donc ça ait du succès on a fait
des grandes expositions toute la france
on a vendu j'ai fait j'ai beaucoup
d'oeuvres a entre autres à périgueux
angoulême à bordeaux dans le sud-ouest à
mulhouse alors après les grandes
fontaines que j'ai fait à mulhouse et
autres c'est un petit peu après mais ce
qui n'empêche bien sûr que c'est une
carte de visite formidable bien que bien
que comme toujours il ya des des combats
d'idées quand même qu'ils sont créés
beaucoup de gens bien pensants
architectes bien en vue qui faisait des
projets nous nous traiter un peu de
piste parce que c'est très bien on
faisait pas des grands immeubles des
gratte ciel et que l'on vient encore la
sculpture représentatif et non
on n'est pas vraiment moi jamais été
vraiment critiquer je veux dire mais il
ya eu des combats d'idées quand même
autour de saint de ces choses là enfin
moi je suis très fier de mon pas votre
présence même là me prouve bien qu'en
fin de compte ça reste vivant que vous
en faites encore des dons on en parle
quoi je dirais que les gens vivent avec
j'ai été sidéré par exemple le maire de
maurepas qui est un jeune homme
il est né à maurepas il est né à mon bas
et je voudrais bien donc vraiment sa
pauvre bien que chez vivant merci
beaucoup encore gérard amon nous avons
reçu ici dans votre atelier parisien
merci sève rageuse en foyer
[Musique]